Every evening, 30-year-old Adesh sits in this
spot, watching television.
This is not his home – he does not have
one.
But Delhi’s cold and polluted winter nights
are a bit easier to bear in this government
shelter for the homeless.
"It is comfortable here.
I come here, watch TV, fall asleep.
I came to Delhi because I can earn more here.
I can work hard all day in the village, but
earn very little."
Adesh first came to Delhi when he was just
14 years old, to try to earn money for his
father’s tuberculosis treatment.
Now, he is the sole wage earner in his family
of three, making 2 to 3 dollars a day working
odd jobs on construction sites.
As the night wears on, the shelter starts
filling up with migrant laborers like Adesh.
Some spots still lie empty.
But this does not mean there are no more people
out in the cold.
As temperatures dip and the city passes them
by, thousands of homeless people in Delhi
try to find a corner to call home for the
night.
Just a 5 minute walk from Adesh’s shelter,
this bridge is a popular spot.
A sealed off portion under it is a home for
many families.
50 year old Lallan has been coming to Delhi
for two decades.
The youngest of his six children lives with
him here.
In the day, the shelter nearby serves as a
makeshift school for her.
But she and her mother cannot spend the night
there, as the shelter is only for men.
"Alcoholics, addicts stay in the shelters.
They fight, they do other things.
How can I take my little children there?
We don’t have a home to live with our kids,
to educate them, keep them clean.
Where is our place?
Under this bridge, that’s all, for the last
20 years we have been lying here."
Last month, Lallan developed a cough because
of the pollution and cold.
He earns 10 to 20 rupees – roughly 25 cents
– for every errand he runs, but missing
a day of work means missing crucial wages
to support his family of 8.
None of Lallan’s so-called neighbors believe
there is a better alternative.
Some don’t know about the government shelters
– others find them insecure.
His children have grown up under this bridge,
but Lallan still dreams of a better future
for them.
"We don’t want our kids to end up like us.
We want them to get good jobs, good homes,
we want that they become good human beings."
For the coming month, however, the only goal
will be to stay warm.